funny we need to move  [Music]  what are you talking about I thought  things were great days had dried up here  [Music]  this would be our fourth move in ten  demerits but money's fine right yeah  right yeah  [Music]  this is a first stone  how about this  it's perfect now that's what we always  wanted  [Music]  is it you're embarrassing and you're  exhausting  I paid our rent by paid for Ben's school  I bought you a car I bought you a horse  I paid for construction on your barn  you're delusional  I'll make money for us for us it's not  for us it's so you can go to fancy  parties and tell people we have horses  for the first time in years I feel  worthwhile I feel powerful you're a poor  kid pretending to be rich you know how  many friends here would have any family  what does it matter so much to you  because I deserve this a lot more  you  [Music]  you